i don't think anybody's made for fame
like i don't think that there's anybody
who's made to thrive in it but i think
there are some people that are more able
to tolerate it just like better equipped
with their emotional and mental tools to
handle it and i don't think i was and it
just made me feel like i was going to
explode all the time i was so anxious
yeah well having an anxiety disorder and
then being approached all the time and
being recognized everywhere sounds
anxiety-provoking
right i think it was eminem he came out
with something and he got really angry
at being approached at a restaurant or
something and me as a kid i was like
well you're a celebrity like what do you
expect and then i know i've noticed
through mainly being around my dad is
and i'm not putting any negativity there
because most people who approach him are
really like really kind and it's been
overwhelmingly positive but it's still
like you know sometimes when you're
having dinner it's like i just want to
have dinner